well it's only Tuesday but the New York
Times has already had an interesting
week it began on Sunday with an article
about age restrictions for tattoos the
piece begins with this anecdote it says
last month a 10 year old boy walked into
the nurse's office of his Elementary
School in Highland New York and asked
for some Vaseline he wanted to rub it
onto his new tattoo a crude rendering of
his name in large block letters on the
inside of his forearm the nurse called
the police the boy had gotten the tattoo
with his mother's permission from a
neighbor according to local authorities
while some states have no minimum age
for receiving a tattoo if a parent
allows it New York State forbids anyone
younger than 18 from getting tattooed
with or without parental consent last
month both the tattoo artist Austin
Smith 20 who was unlicensed and the
boy's mother Crystal Thomas 33 were
arrested as picture of the pictures of
the boy's arms stirred outrage across
local international news sites and
social media
well we're then told that tattoos are
becoming more and more common and
socially acceptable which is not exactly
news to most of us the worst thing about
tattoos now is that they're cliched
since everyone has them and I say that
as somebody who has two as we're told
however Most states forbid children
those under the age of 18 from getting
these permanent markings on their bodies
yet 12 States or so around a dozen
states do allow tattoos on children with
no minimum age requirement at all as
long as they have parental consent back
to the article it says it is a situation
that Dr Cora Bruner a pediatrician and
professor at the University of
Washington Medical Center Seattle
Children's Hospital and author of
guidance on tattoos for pediatricians
issued by the American Academy
pediatrician pediatric medicine finds
troubling quote it is a permanent Mark
or a symbol you're putting on your body
I don't think kids under 18 have that
kind of agency to make a decision Dr
Bruner said we need to look at these
laws again
now personally I couldn't agree more
children do not have agency to make
permanent life-altering decisions it's
good to hear that the American Academy
of Pediatrics has reached this Common
Sense conclusion like most people the
American Academy of Pediatrics can
clearly see when it comes to tattoos
that children are impulsive suggestible
unable to Think Through the consequences
in fact the Times article Ends by
telling us that everyone involved in the
tattooing of the ten-year-old now
regrets it it says Miss Thomas the
parents in Highland New York uh near
Poughkeepsie described her case as a
misunderstanding she said she favored
age limits and that she had mistakenly
believed her son was asking for
permission to get a temporary tattoo no
little child should get tattooed she'd
said she has been charged with
endangering the welfare of a child a few
days after he was reigned and Lloyd in
Lloyd justice court on charges of
dealing unlawfully with a child a
misdemeanor that can entail up to a year
in prison Mr Smith the tattoo artist
said that he is racked with deep regret
over tattooing the 10 year old quote
it's the worst mistake I've made in my
life he said at the time I thought that
if you got your parents permission you
could get a tattoo as for Miss Thomas's
son today he feels differently about Mr
Smith's agreeing to give him a tattoo
quote he should have said no the boy
said
no you may be skeptical about the
mother's excuse here it's hard to see
how a misunderstanding could result in a
10 year old getting tattooed but the
point is that most people including the
American Academy Pediatrics
recognize that there is no good reason
to make these types of body
modifications to a child
yet it's hard not to notice
that their views on a child's ability to
consent and the propriety of making
permanent physical alterations to a
minor who lacks agency
seem to be rather inconsistent
after all the AAP also fully endorses
medical and surgical gender transitions
for children
the very group that when it comes to
tattoos they readily admit lack the
capacity to consent
this is not cognitive dissonance on the
part of the medical establishment for
them it's fully intentional
they know exactly what they're doing
they want you to have the cognitive
dissonance
they're trying to create or at least
exacerbate
a mental disconnect in your head
whereby you adopt an entirely different
set of values and priorities and
fundamental beliefs depending on the
topic
when it comes to tattoos you're meant to
see children as children incapable of
making these kinds of long-term choices
when it comes to gender transition
suddenly even a five-year-old possesses
agency the capacity for long-term
thinking
a deep and mature internal sense of what
is best for their own well-being
this is how the gender ideology game has
always worked as proponents want you to
see gender as its own world its own
Universe where entirely different
scientific and moral laws obtain the
whole thing comes crashing down once you
simply apply the same scrutiny to gender
ideology that you apply to everything
else
and that's why it's interesting that the
New York Times printed another story on
the same day which for the five people
who still read the print edition
appeared on the same page
and this one is titled they paused
puberty but is there a cost puberty
blockers can ease transgender use
anguish and buy time to weigh options
but concerns are growing about long-term
physical effects and other consequences
now the article is somewhat tentative in
its criticisms of puberty blockers but
it does say this quote
as the number of adolescents who
identify as transgender grows drugs
known as puberty blockers have become
the first line of intervention for the
youngest one seeking medical treatment
their use is typically framed as a safe
and reversible way to buy time to weigh
a medical transition and avoid the
anguish of growing into a body that
feels wrong transgender adolescents
suffer from disproportionately high
rates of depression other mental health
issues studies show that the drugs have
eased some patients gender dysphoria
distress over the mismatch of their
birth sex and gender identity but as an
increasing number of adolescents
identifies transgender in the United
States an estimated 300 000 aged 13 to
17 and an Untold number who are younger
concerns are growing among some medical
professionals about the consequences of
the drugs according to a New York Times
examination the questions are fueling
government reviews in Europe prompting a
push for more research and leading some
prominent Specialists to reconsider at
what age to prescribe them and for how
long a small number of doctors won't
recommend them at all there is emerging
evidence of potential harm from using
privy blockers according to reviews of
scientific papers and interviews with
more than 50 doctors and academic
experts around the world
we're then given a brief and incomplete
list of some of the complications from
these drugs but these are important
complications to list anyway it says the
drugs suppress estrogen's testosterone
hormones that help develop the
reproductive system but also affect the
bones the brain and other parts of the
body
during puberty bone mass typically
surges determining a lifetime of bone
health when adolescents are using
blockers bone density growth flat lines
on average according to an analysis
commission by the times of the
observational studies examining the
effects many doctors treating trans
patients believe they will recover that
loss when they go off the blockers but
two studies from the from the analysis
attract trans patients bone strength
while using blockers and through the
first years of sex hormone treatment
found that many do not fully rebound and
lag behind their peers that could lead
to heightened risks of debilitating
fractures earlier than will be expected
from normal aging in their 50s instead
of 60s and more immediate harm for
patients who start treatment with
already weak bones experts say
quote there's going to be a price said
Dr Sandeep kosla who uh leads a bone
research lab at the Mayo Clinic and the
price is probably going to be some
deficit in skeletal Mass
now the article does provide equal space
or better in fact better than equal
space to the other side quote unquote
and this mostly consists of lengthy
anecdotes and quotes from various
medical professionals making wild
assumptions about the totally
unsubstantiated alleged benefits of the
drugs
that doesn't matter
the point is that the New York Times is
acknowledging the criticisms of these
practices and even providing an accurate
though incomplete accounting of them
they are um in other words
legitimizing the debate
acknowledging that there is a valid
reason to doubt the mainstream consensus
now to be clear about this
I'm not giving them credit okay I'm not
I'm not applauding the New York Times
I'm not going to applaud them or
nominate them for a Pulitzer they're a
decade late to the party
and they had to be dragged Kicking and
Screaming to this point
we dragged them here because we are
shifting the Overton window
we are forcing the most mainstream media
institutions to take these arguments
seriously to give them an airing for
once
I mean none of us who've been in the
trenches on this issue will ever get
credit for the New York Times of course
they're not going to quote us they're
not going to say as so-and-so has always
said they're not going to do it but that
doesn't matter
we've done this and you could forget
about the election for a moment okay
um we are still winning Republican
politicians in many states may not be
but on this issue and other cultural
issues we are seeing progress this is
progress
and it's significant because the left
and this is on all issues but especially
this one of gender ideology
the left relies on manufactured
consensus
okay they can't defend their position
they can't do that
so instead they pretend that no other
position but theirs even exists
they present this united front which is
totally a facade
and they don't allow any opinion but
their own to be heard oxygen deprivation
is their greatest weapon they try to
suffocate the other side they declare
everyone agrees
even though everyone doesn't agree
but the people don't who don't agree
don't get a hearing they don't get a
platform
and they keep declaring it that everyone
agrees until eventually in in so many
cases history shows everyone really does
agree
you know they can kind of manifest it if
they say there's a consensus and they
say it long enough and loud enough
then eventually a consensus sort of
forms they've manufactured one
now if they allow the other side to be
heard
then the public will know that there is
another side
and even that the other side is
reasonable and making evidence-based
logical arguments
the manufactured consensus crumbles
and their agenda goes down with it
I I predict that we will see and we are
now beginning to see this very thing
happening with gender ideology
we have punctured the manufactured
consensus bubble
and now we're going to see it all come
apart and that'll do it for this portion
of the show as we move over to the
members block hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]